the federal government has long seen lie
detectors as useful in interrogations
they don't want people to feel that they
can beat a lie-detector test
Chad Dixon a 34 year old Indiana man was
sentenced to federal prison for the
crime of teaching how to beat polygraphs
he was indeed out of work so he saw this
as a way to keep his house from going
into foreclosure
Dixon taught between 70 to a hundred
people how polygraphs are conducted and
counter measures
Marissa Taylor has been covering Dixon's
case for McClatchy Newspapers
by teaching someone to lie during a
polygraph and if you know that their lie
that they're going to lie to the federal
government then you could be guilty of
obstruction of justice
much of what Dixon taught can be found
in books and online so why the sudden
prosecution with Snowden and this
crackdown on what the federal government
calls insider threats people who are
within the government who might leak
information who might unpause a threat
to employees like they don't want people
to feel that they can beat a
lie-detector test have you engaged in
espionage against the United States and
you're going to answer no for the feds
polygraphs are accurate tools used to
judge their employees trustworthiness
and to prevent leaks the polygraph is
basically an instrument that helps
detect if somebody's being honest or
dishonest on specific issues
Darryl debo works at the Virginia school
of polygraph which teaches how to
conduct polygraph tests some of the
things that we look at what the
polygraph is your blood pressure your
pulse rate and your Galvan exten
response this chair from Lafayette
instrument company measures their feet
it measures anything to do with their
arms headphones which measure any type
of facial eye movements so basically
every part of your body is measured and
according to de Boehm a professional
polygraph examiner can detect the
techniques of cheating that Dixon was
teaching making the government's fear of
infiltration by trained liars look
more bizarre we're trained in all those
type of countermeasures these are very
antiquated things that are out there
that people still do try but they're so
antiquated we know when they're doing it
scientists aren't convinced though
because lie detectors only measure
physiological responses it isn't
difficult to fool a polygraph the
polygraph is not a lie detector there is
no unique physiological signature that
is associated with lying
Stephen Aftergood is a senior research
analyst at the Federation of American
scientists there are techniques that can
be used to suppress the kinds of signals
that a polygraph measures you can learn
to regulate your heartbeat you can learn
to control your breath and you can
generate spurious signals that will
change the sort of baseline that the
polygraph is set to Chad Dixon is
currently serving eight months but he
isn't the only one the government is
interested in marissa taylor in a report
showed that Customs and Border
Protection collected a list of people
who just bought books on polygraphs
these people were listed there were more
than almost 5,000 people on their names
their social security numbers other
occupations their addresses and they
were sent to the IRS the CIA the NSA
they do acknowledge just the average
person has the right to a buy a book but
the government says we have a right to
know whether you've bought that book
because of the national security
implications so it's a case of national
security trumping on any First Amendment
interest